fresh from the room not even an hour old
there's baby girls already at risk and
taken away from the woman who gave her
life
but who could also cause her death
both her parents have coronavirus and
that means the nurses must assume
the baby could be infected too
[Music]
the little girl known only as baby a is
weighed
and checked she has slight breathing
problems
which are causing concern the miracle of
birth is fraught with anxiety
and overshadowed by a disease which can
kill
[Music]
they run a series of tests including
using a hood to aid her first gumps of
air
being born in a global pandemic to a
mother with the virus
puts this little girl in a unique
category about which
medics still know very little
they're still not happy and it's decided
she needs to be moved to the covered
baby intensive care
the first sensation this baby had on
entering the world wasn't the comfort of
her mother's body but a pcr test for
covid
she'll have a second in 48 hours
she's alone possible spreader possible
patient
with no human contact allowed
no baby born at this hospital to a
covered positive mother has been
infected through the womb
but they won't take chances
so this room looks like being her home
for the next few weeks
they have a zero mortality rate here
coronavirus has meant they often have to
induce the births
but there's little pushback if they know
that
it's better to give birth to the baby
they say yes and they get happy
and even they say that save my baby
first expressed milk is brought to the
baby
taken before the mother begins her
coronavirus treatment
after this the baby will have formula
milk to avoid any risk
it feels strange to her
but it's still a comfort although it's
the closest contact she'll have with her
mother
until she's out of the danger zone a
handful of babies born to infected
mothers here
have gone on to contract the disease but
probably through skin to skin transfer
so baby a will be apart from her mother
for the next fortnight at least
it's a very lonely start in life for
these covered babies
alex crawford sky news istanbul